so how are you guys doing today good
good thanks you good very good
it's raining but which is great Nelly I
know I missed the rain I really do
some Fox Lux starts in a very jarring
jarring way I'm wondering if the script
started that way and what your thoughts
were on the first read-through
yeah the script did sort that way like
it was a pretty read you're like whoa
already were weather and but I think
that made the script like so much more
interesting there wasn't you know trying
to get the audience to settle in or you
know it's just giving it to them as it
was um so yeah I guess that's what I
thought that was a really interesting
thing to do on the Bradys well yeah
Brady when we first talked about the
film before I even read it he said my
first film happened between World War 1
and World War 2 and this film I wanted
to think what are the defining Wars of
our era because there's not sort of
conventional war in our country at least
and he was saying that you know we sort
of had this civil war of like school
shootings and this foreign war of terror
attacks and that's kind of those are the
wars that we're living with and that
this story kind of bridges those and has
to do with you know how we're
interacting with the violence that we
live in in our culture and that was
really really interesting to me too like
that he put a pop star in the middle of
it because you see really the
relationship between pop culture and
violence it was interesting that this
movie has a lot of shots but the camera
is sort of following you is it sort of a
long take with camera is behind your
backs and your time the conversation I'm
wondering what you thought that added to
the film and what that does for your
performance having the camp behind you
while you sort of just interact with
your environment in front of you I love
it because it allowed I love having
these long takes because then you can do
the scene in its entirety and so it's
kind of
Theatre almost and then having it behind
you it always kind of puts the viewer in
the characters head because they're
seeing the world as you see it I mean
behind you but still like they've got
your point of view so it's um it's a
great I was like it in relation to the
audience because I feel like they can
relate to you more but I think like I
always talk about this eleventh but the
diner scene I was my favorite scene you
know to do and it's one of my favorites
in the film because we were just kind of
given you know this script dialogue and
it was such a long tape that and he just
let us completely go through it no cuts
and the camera was on a head switch yeah
I would haven't thought of that person
the audience and perspective just call
me up and you also bought postings that
include very intense choreography dance
choreography and but there's also a
sense that you're very much acting to as
you dance there's there's a performance
going on besides the dance and wondering
how you you balance that in your head
the sort of you have to remember the
steps you have to remember the dance
stuff you're also a character you're
also living in this character's head and
what I was quite lucky because my
choreography didn't wasn't supposed to
be like funny nailed because she was
still kind of new to there and to the
whole industry and so I could kind of
focus more on the character as opposed
to the dancing but I guess it's inborn
the character is dancing and you're
living their life you know um you know
you don't usually dance so yeah so I
just a lot more intense yeah I think I
think with every anytime there's like a
like a physical thing or even an accent
that you have to do I feel like you just
like rehearse it until you can't
rehearse anymore like you just do it
until it's second nature and then you
can just be in this
so said I did I just worked on it a lot
I was interesting that there's there's
two scenes one with young girls last one
oh there where they makes a point to to
mention that she lost her hotel key if
there's any sort of a larger theme to
that or that was just sort of a way of
displaying what kind of person she is
for me it wasn't like a metaphor was
just kind of like a typical like the
kind of person who's used to other
people doing stuff for them all the time
you know it infantilizes you in a way
and makes you like a kid when you're
like losing stuff I mean and it's kind
of that's what happens around famous
people a lot I think is just like
there's a lot of people allowing the
person to be irresponsible and I'm like
a kid I really like the line that you
say I don't want people to think too
hard I just want them to feel good we
talk about pop music but you both don't
do a lot of fluff the movies you do a
very very very very intelligent what
your perspective is on that line is
there there is truth to it but at the
same time it's it's it odd way to look
at art I'm just wondering how you guys
and what I love puppies I kind of think
that's probably why like you don't have
to there are so many things that you do
have to properly you know engage with
them think but with pop music just you
know listen and and relax so um I feel
like I'd take that quite literally like
you literally do just listen and and
relax so I don't know if I had much of a
deeper in a sunny event
yeah I think that it's really about pop
culture in general that sort of that's
the like one line version of why exists
and I think there's like purpose for all
of it like there I know with myself
there's times that I just want to like
like you were saying kind of just chill
out and not have like some kind of like
extreme emotional or intellectual
responses I mean and then there's times
that I real
name something that I like engage with
or that like challenges me or you know
makes me like think about it or feel
about it for weeks you know and and I
think that there's room for all of it
you